well people of the internet that
certainly did not take long just a few
days after we got official news on the
hogwarts legacy character creator with a
brief snippet shared by chandler wood
along with some very fancy clothing for
the game we now have a leak a major leak
guys and in terms of leaks this is about
as close to official as it gets and
honestly i mean considering all the
actual legitimate news that we've gotten
about hogwarts legacy lately i kind of
forgot about leaks but yeah they're
still a thing so why do i say this one
is so legit well this was posted on
reddit and we got to give credit to the
user opel element on reddit as they are
the one who found this and essentially
what we have here is some text that was
hidden within the code of the official
hogwarts legacy website that's why i say
it's about as close to official as it
gets but there is a pretty big caveat
with this and we're going to talk about
that now by the time this video comes
out or maybe by the time you're seeing
it it is very possible that these words
will no longer be hidden within the code
and on most browsers i know for sure
this works on chrome because that's how
i tested it you can push control you
command you if you're on a mac and then
that's going to show you the full html
code of that website so you'll notice a
lot of the familiar words are words that
you actually see on the page itself now
i have no idea how they found this if
they're just a coder who was kind of
scrolling endlessly or if they started
searching for specific things but
because they have already found these
words now you can just do control f or
command f if you're on a mac and you can
search for these eight terms that all
appear one thestral mount two dark arts
cosmetic pack three dark arts battle
arena four dark arts garrison hat
five 72 hours early access to the game
six kelpie robe
seven steel case and eight floating
ancient magic wand with book now this
user also mentions that there are some
separate labels of digital only and
digital deluxe only which is a clear
indication of a plan for having multiple
versions of this game quite possibly a
collector's edition as well even though
i gotta be clear here we do not see the
word collector's edition use anywhere
and all those items there i think it's
pretty clear that most of them are
digital in-game items but when it comes
to the steel case and the floating
ancient magic wand with book those two
certainly sound more like physical items
to me which i think would be part of a
collector's edition so now i mentioned
there was a big caveat here what's the
big caveat well the caveat is that just
because this appears on the hogwarts
legacy website hidden within the code
even though we know hey this definitely
came from wb came from avalanche it is
official in those terms it hasn't been
announced so all this means is that
these words were at some point in their
plans now they could have put this in
there as a placeholder this could have
been the coder actually testing things
out the person who designs their website
they could be typing these in to see
okay we're gonna test this out we're
gonna see how this would show up they
could actually have been planned at some
point and this could be the exact
announcement that we get here in a few
days weeks months who knows of certain
extras of certain dlc of certain
pre-order bonuses that could be
associated with different versions of
the game but again it has not been made
official it has not been announced so
these are all subject to change there
could be more here that we don't even
see on this list that they're going to
add when they finally do or if they do
hopefully they do announce a collector's
edition but my point here is there could
be more than what's on this list there
could be less or it could actually be
this exact list so as exciting as this
is and i'm not gonna give my usual take
it with a grain of salt because i think
you could take this one as being pretty
reliable considering where it was found
you do have to just keep in mind that
this stuff may never see the light of
day these plans could be completely
scrapped now i'll link this reddit post
down in the description below i highly
encourage you to read through the entire
post because it explains how they found
this and this user has also done a great
deal of research to kind of look at some
of the things that wb has done in the
past they speculate that the steel case
could potentially be a best buy
exclusive i really hope not i really
hope not i hope that we are getting a
full kind of big big big collector's
edition for hogwarts legacy and they
also speculated how these in-game
digital items may work because obviously
if they're giving them away as a bonus
of some kind for either pre-ordering or
buying an extra edition then there has
to be something special about them are
they going to be locked away to only
people who buy that version personally i
don't think so i think instead they're
gonna be something that you can unlock
early and then everyone else will be
able to get later in the game by playing
it naturally we already know they've
confirmed no micro transactions are in
the game at all so you don't have to
worry about that and also it seems i
don't think we can say this is
confirmation but this seems to be a
pretty strong indicator that thestral
mounts will also be in the game so in
addition to being able to ride on
hippogriff in addition to being able to
ride by broomstick it seems that we are
able to add thestral to that list as
well hopefully we will get something
officially official soon but until then
you can check out my speculation of what
i would absolutely love to see in a
hogwarts legacy collector's edition i
posted on the right side of your screen
now you guys know where to find all the
latest hogwarts legacy news theories and
discussion right here youtube.com retro
rack and tour if you're new make sure
you hit that subscribe button before you
go as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon